2014 the year that the xbox 360 and
playstation 3 begin their long slow
slide into obsolescence and you look at
these nominee lists and like this is
still an awesome platform to own dragon
age inquisition southpark ground zeroes
titanfall so many good ones but dark
souls 2 took it kevin van org reviewer
dark souls 2 would have funkin really i
mean it's interesting because it's easy
to point out where you know places where
you think dark souls 1 did it better or
maybe you think dark souls 2 to their
it's sort of a thankless place for dark
souls 2 to be in a way you know you
can't make everybody happy with the
sequel but I what I really like is that
Dark Souls 2 still sort of stands on its
own it does some things that are
different enough and unique enough that
you can actually stop thinking about
dark souls and just focus on dark souls
2 itself as being a wonderful adventure
I'm certainly a bigger adventure than
its than its predecessor just in terms
of the incredible amount of surface area
it covers and the incredible number of
environments they're very memorable like
I remember maybe not quite to the extent
is some of those early parts of Dark
Souls that stick in everybody's minds
forever but holy cow when you go to like
the the Bastille the lost the steel in
dark souls and see this crumbling place
and and it upholds that fine tradition
of pushing you to areas you've already
been to and still forcing you to think
about everything you're doing even
though you've done it a dozen times
before you still can't take anything for
granted and that's one of the things I
love a lot of series and one of the
things that continues with restless very
rarely do games do like large and
difficult well like it's either very big
and there's a lot to do or it's short
and makes you want to cry and break
things but dark souls 2 did it but I
think it's also interesting to point out
that we we had at
truly a Dark Souls light this year in
Lords of the Fallen and I think what
that game did and then we can look back
at dark souls 2 is say there's more to
this formula than just the challenge
alone there's more to it that makes this
special it's the sense of adventure it's
that the sense of accomplishing
something you know in seeing new sights
and looking at things you've never seen
in a game before and finding your own
way and trying to make your paths
replace that's not quick to reveal its
soul to you I mean I think you just take
away the challenge and I still think you
have something so incredibly remarkable
and i love that dark souls 2 still has
that essence
you